now we can bring you some breaking news
now uh the European Central Bank has
announced its latest interest rate
decision so let's find out what's
happened our business correspondent in
King is in the city for us so in
Fullerton hello Jana yes that's right
the European Central Bank in the last
few moments has raised its main policy
rate by a quarter of one percent that
takes its main deposit rate from three
percent to three and a quarter percent
uh it represents us slowing down at the
pace at which the European Central Bank
has been raising interest rates its last
three policy decisions in December
February and March saw it on each
occasion raised interest rates by half
of one percent in fact since July last
year it's gone from minus uh 0.5 to uh
three percent until now they're gone
again today to three and a quarter
percent but it is interesting that
they've slowed down the pace at which
they are raising interest rates and I
think the reasoning behind that is
because there are concerns that in some
parts of the Eurozone uh the economy is
not going uh growing as rapidly as they
would have been liking it to
particularly in Germany obviously the
biggest and single most important member
of the Eurozone the economy stagnated
there during the first three months of
the year but obviously inflation Remains
the main concern for the ECB now
interestingly in the latest figures that
we've had out uh the headline rate of
inflation in the Eurozone Rose from 6.9
in March to seven percent in April and
that is obviously more than three times
the central Target rate that the ECB
seeks to pursue for inflation of two
percent so the Central Bank didn't
really have any option uh but to raise
interest rates again so the big debate
has been whether they'd raise by a
quarter of one percent or half of one
percent and I think probably those
figures out of Germany have tipped the
balance on the other side of that there
have been some indications that the
Eurozone remains in relatively robust
health for example in unemployment well
that's roughly at its lowest level at
six and a half percent or so since the
Euro was uh created so there has been
some mixed data there but as I say it's
a slowing at the pace in which the
Eurozone raises interest rate European
Central about raises interest rates and
in doing so Anna you would say that it's
actually in keeping with what we got
from the U.S federal reserve last night
they also raised their main policy rate
by a quarter of one percent but
indicated that that was probably as much
as they would do for the time being so
for a lot of people this will be quite
encouraging uh in that it points out to
the fact that central banks around the
world are now starting to uh ease the
rate at which they are hiking rates and
people I imagine will be looking for the
bank of England to do the same a week
today
interesting yeah we'll be back with you
more on that then but in for the moment
thanks very much indeed